you know I will say this if the Dark
Knight taught us anything is that people
love magic tricks and Heath Ledger does
him Steve Carell does him I don't know
[Music]
the incredible Burt Wonderstone there
was supposed to be pyro there so the
incredible Burt Wonderstone stars Steve
Carell and he plays Burt Wonderstone
he's a Vegas magician he has his partner
Steve Buscemi and they've been doing the
same magic act for about ten years now
and the whole thing's kind of getting
tired in this new slick really dangerous
street magician played by Jim Carrey
comes on the scene has street magic on
the Vegas strip it's really weird and
dangerous you know like Criss Angel
mind for concede long hair and eyeliner
and you need to tuck really slow like
this because if you tuck like Criss
Angel it's almost like you've actually
had coupling with the Beast
no offense to Criss Angel he actually
has some really cool in the world
but this movie plays on the relevance of
that situation people used to love
really big Vegas magic action oh really
glamorous flashy outfits and at a point
they were like no we like David Blaine
and Criss Angel and those really real
street magicians that do really weird
dark but it's right in front of
your face what freaks you out no I feel
like I'm gonna be in the minority in
this review because a lot of people are
like it's not good I'm not saying Burt
Wonderstone is great I'm saying I had a
good time in the movie first of all I
love magic movies you got to refuse it
for stage and there that is if you're
looking for that comment it is in the
comments section over and over
inevitably I do appreciate you guys want
to hear my opinion on the myriad of
things in the world back to this review
that Burt Wonderstone was a bit annoying
at first the first I was like you're a
dick
there's no denying that the guy is a
pompous dick funny because when I was
watching the movie I was like I'm pretty
sure this role was written for Will
Ferrell and if not him Jim Carrey's role
was somewhere in this movie I'm pretty
sure Will Ferrell was supposed to be in
it and at a point he just he just wasn't
i enjoyed the message in the movie which
is you can get paid more to do more of
what you love but at a point when it
starts becoming a job you might want to
pull back and go back to doing what you
love the money doesn't matter it's not
about the money it's about the enjoyment
of doing what you do I mean the movie is
bogged down by a few things one of the
factors is no character in this movie is
special I feel like there are quite a
few actors that could have played any
one of these characters in this movie no
one in this movie makes the characters
there
you know that kind of wasted potential
toys a bummer to see another thing is
the movies a bit too long it was just a
bit shorter 15-20 minutes shorter would
have been a perfect length but instead
you're like alright the movies dragging
on a bed but even with these flaws I had
a good time with the movie I enjoyed the
magic of the movie I enjoyed the
conflict between the magician's in the
movie in the end I paid 10 bucks to see
this movie and I wasn't pissed about it
and that's actually something I'm gonna
say this movie is a good time no alcohol
required subtext at matinee price you
start paying your 15 bucks a ticket for
it you're gonna come back and be like
Jeremy you're a dick but I said Matt
name so don't mistake them at this point
I would usually ask you a question and
say comment below let me know but I'm
gonna thank you for a second in this
review and I was talking about it's
important to do what you love and bigger
isn't always better and it's important
just to have fun doing what you love and
doing your hobby I think you all for
letting me do that I mean a lot of times
people are like Jeremy weren't you on TV
and the answers simple because I enjoy
doing this this is my hobby I don't have
a boss I don't care how much money
people throw at me I still will not
wanna boss when I was watching Burt
Wonderstone that's what happened at Burt
Wonderstone he was like oh I love doing
this then he signed a big contract and
now he hates doing it because he does
the same every day and he has to
fill seats and it just becomes a job but
I was watching it I really connected
with that premise I was like I don't
ever want to become like Burt
Wonderstone I thank you all for watching
my videos and allowing me to do what I
do which is just do my hobby it's just
me and you here and that's pretty badass
so thank you all for that I know that is
I really haven't a question for you but
if you want to comment below go for it
comment below let me know whatever you
want to let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you